you wanted to buy the rights for the
film Todd had already bought them and
then you called him and said this is one
messed up dude if you ever make this
film but I know he ended up calling you
and sort of begging you to play the role
it was cool that he was like really
persistent in in getting me to play the
part and I'm really glad I did I think
because he's such an insane character
and with a lot of layers to him and then
also just the story itself is so
unbelievable you know because most
stories that are really insane are
happening to people in their like 30s or
40s I feel like because they're more
like established in life so when
something an insane true story happens
and your young actor and the person is
around your age you immediately go like
wow could I play that person you know
one of the quotes I love from the film
is how you found a crack in the door and
kicked it the hell open is there a
moment in your life or in your career
where the door was open a crack and you
felt like you kicked it open and found
your hustle I think very few people get
into this business and the business is
just wide open you know usually you kind
of got to show people what what you want
to be because they're not gonna they're
not going to know that more than more
than you and you know they don't always
have a big imagination with what you're
capable of I have said this is my
favorite film of 2016 Wow thank you I
think you've said before that you love
films about guys or people that make bad
decisions yeah cuz I've noticed it's
about an ordinary ordinary guy finding
his swagger
yeah that's something that yeah yeah I
like guys who sort of find their
confidence and find their you know um
their things so to speak but but you're
right in the bad decisions thing is
always because it sort of leads to
mayhem I have a spray-tan addiction in
your personal life personal life but I
know you had to spray-tan for this film
yeah did you have the same issue or
could you not wait to get sort of away
from it after you buy a house you're not
ready to finish and never look back
really did you have to do all the
different positions yeah
she moved me around like he was twister
basic David work on runners
gosh you guys
you